i'm always happy to talk with you uh let
me start by saying uh i'm really happy
the film was made i'm so happy when more
presentation gets out there uh so i
really do hope it's a huge hit for you
guys thank you i really appreciate that
um so i have a ton of questions but i
have to start with what for me uh might
be one of the most important things
which is um what is actually happening
with super troopers three winter
soldiers we have written draft seven
and so when we get to about draft 20
we'll we'll start the machine up is it
does it really work like that with you
guys yeah i mean we wrote 32 drafts of
super troopers one and we wrote 30
drafts of super troopers 2.
it's just our process
but i will tell you this we have a movie
called quasi which we made uh it's going
to come out december on hulu and it's a
13th century french
it's like murder assassination mystery i
play the king of france
paul soder plays the pope and steve
lenny plays a hunchback and it's a big
international sort of it's like a it's a
monty python movie uh i know kevin
directed that that's right british
accents the whole i can't wait number
one but number two does and i know my
last thing on this but does a lot change
between like draft five and 15 when
you're writing or are you sort of just
tweaking scenes if you will no the 5 to
15 a lot does change a lot will throw
out entire plot lines and reorganize
everything and bring back plot lines and
it's a it's a it's a it's a process but
eventually we get there uh you've
directed a lot of tv yeah and i'm just
curious what is it like for you stepping
into the different because every show
has its own aesthetic and its own way of
doing things what is it like for you as
a director when you're stepping in on
say resident alien or some of the other
things you've done trying to sort of you
know hit their thing but also make it
your own well i just directed a show
with rob lowe called unstable which is a
new netflix show that he and his son are
doing john john oh and lo
and you know i
i
watch their pilot and go okay i get i
get which lenses they're using and they
seem to want to use a lot of two shots
and and then i sit with the
the the head writer on set and we shoot
the show and i and i say you know
if i were working for another company i
would shoot a bunch of singles here he
goes i'll never use them
and i said okay
so i'm going to make these two shots
perfect as though i would have singles
and it's about rhythm you know it's
about taking out the pauses it's about
pausing when you're supposed to and
for me comedy is entirely about
uh pace rhythm and pace rhythm and pace
and luckily the the
victor fresco who runs that that show
agrees uh jumping into why i get to talk
to you um what was it about this
material that said oh i want to be
involved in this well i'm a joe coy fan
and it was his first movie and he'd
never acted before and they said can you
kind of go up there and make sure we end
up with a good movie
uh and i you know and i it's to me it's
important for joe to succeed
like because
he's so successful as a stand-up i'd
hate for him to have a situation where
you know he came into a movie and it
didn't quite work out and so i'm a
stand-up he's a stand-up so i said to
him we got to make a really funny movie
because people are going to expecting it
to be
you know they're not like hey filipinos
are in it's great they're gonna they're
gonna want to be a really funny movie
and then we'll also have all these
filipinos in it and then that part will
sort of advance the cause and so we
agreed
to just make sure we've made like a you
know full-on funny movie i feel like
the last few years there's been more
representation in hollywood at least not
a ton but more how do you look at it in
terms of what's been going on the last
few years i think that you know
representation is sort of a step-by-step
thing there was a point where
you know it used to be
the immigrants were newer and so more of
the characters had
sort of their accents and it was played
for laughs right i mean
but it doesn't mean that was a bad time
or that was wrong it was just the way it
was right i mean there was a point where
they used to put india they played white
guys in brown face with peter sellers
it wasn't wrong it was just the way it
was but it's we're progressing right now
here i am i've directed this movie with
like a largely filipino cast and a
couple indians and it's like it's
progress right so
you know we got to kind of give
ourselves a little bit of a break here
you know like like they will look back
on this time period in 2040 and go oh
they were racist and they didn't do
enough of this and it's like okay well i
don't judge i don't judge uh the
the past by futures uh but but i don't
judge the past by the presence
new rules
so i think we're making great progress i
mean you know and i think the thing to
look at is crazy rotations and how well
that did and you go wow
that wasn't just asian people going i
mean it was all sorts of people were in
that audience and and
and it worked commercially and so if you
work commercially the reason easter
sunday got made is because crazy rich
asians did so well and if this movie can
do well then more movies will get made
because of the business part of show
business that is literally the reason
i'm sitting in this room wanting to help
you promote this movie because i want
more representation in hollywood and the
truth is it will only happen financially
when they make money hollywood will say
we can do more as they should there's a
these are expensive films you don't just
get to have a movie because you're of a
certain race it's just not how the
system works uh you made me laugh in the
movie with the lines about i'm losing
you the reception in the canyon um when
did you realize you wanted to play the
role and who came up with that uh
specific joke about you know the agent
well like when i signed up for the movie
the first thing i the first thing i
don't do is say hey i want to be in it
because i i want to be
hired as a director and not
there i don't want people to think oh
he's going to shove himself in it so
luckily while we were casting in order
to come up and play that role which was
a two day part you had to
quarantine for 14 days
and you know we went to some
famous people
and they're like i i can't come up there
and sit in a in an apartment for 14 days
just to work too and i was like all
right and so over time amblin was like
look if no one comes up here you're
playing the park and i was like hey you
know if you need me i'll play the part
i'm here already it's up to you i'm not
advocating for myself for sure and it
came down to it they're like will you
play the part and i'm like of course
i'll play the part and then the joke
itself the main joke which is that
my character keeps hanging up on joe coy
because he pretends to be going over
mulholland
the what the the one of the writers kate
angelo is convinced that her agent sits
at his desk and pretends to be on
mulholland and hangs up on her tiffany
haddish is very very funny in the movie
there's a great scene with her at the
car how much is that sort of scripted
how much is that of them finding it in
the moment can you sort of take me
through that well she came up because of
her close friendship with joe coy they
were they they were teenagers doing
stand-up together she tiffany would take
care of joe's baby when joe would go and
do a set and he'd come back and she'd be
changing his diapers so there were she
who worked i think three days on the
movie and she came up in quarantine for
14. and she's such a big
famous
talented star
that we made sure that we wrote her
uh
a lot of
of what i think are like really high-end
jokes and so
so we wrote this scene and i'm like if
you only say these jokes
i can pretty much guarantee that this is
going to work and of course it's a cop
pullover and i've shot
20 cop pull over so i'm like i got that
part it's more
what you know the shape of their
relationship and what the jokes are and
so we wrote her a bunch of great jokes
and then she and joe
spent about
five hours the night before she came on
set
and they just created all sorts of
little riffs and riffs off the jokes and
you know but they riffed within the
structure of the scene and so when i got
there the next day they're like we got
these five refs i'm like what are they
and they should tell them like yes of
course sure of course yes let's shoot
them all and so we shot all these little
riffs and then
you know between i've done a lot of
improv and tiffany's done you know and
so we just would improv with like a
like a cap on it we'd just sort of be
very structured and you know that sort
of riff she does about
naming the baby subie you know instead
of not mercedes not lexus not even tesla
not tessie that was all her but it was
like you know she did it once and i'm
like go with that thing and then she
would go with that thing but yeah she
you know she improvised a good number of
great jokes what was it like for you in
the editing room uh in terms of when you
have comedians that are delivering
possibly of great alts what is it like
picking and choosing what you actually
want to use well i like it because i get
to choose right and so i just picked my
favorite uh and and you know sometimes
i'll cut something
you know that i wasn't so sure about
like i wasn't sure about joe kissing lou
diamond phillips fingers
and then somebody
way at the end of the process was like
what about that thing where he kisses
his fingers and i'm like we really want
to do that and they're like yeah okay so
i've cut it into the movie and we showed
a crowd and they roared and i'm like
glad you said so that leads me to my
next thing uh
talk a little bit about what you learned
about the movie from friends and family
screenings and test screenings that like
impacted the finished film
well uh
you know they they first of all the
movie got good laughs right so we were
we were relieved uh that we were going
to be entertaining
uh and second of all it felt like um
people connected to the concept which is
a big concept of having a uh
a family and weird uncles and ball
breaking mother and they were kind of
like this is sort of
a pretty universal uh
dynamic
uh and that was that was nice to sort of
see because those i mean
when you decide to make a movie and
you're involved in writing the script
you're really just trying to
say i believe this is the way it should
be and i'm going to prove it to you and
then you see the audience react and you
go see
and and i know that's like
cocky and whatever but that's all we're
doing i mean you know
the show part of
show business is show showing off
uh and and and we were happy that that
the theory we had was proved correct you
obviously were not making a marvel movie
you had a budget that you needed you
know what i mean and so i'm curious what
was uh the toughest stuff the things
that you were most nervous about being
able to pull off with the time and
budget that you had well the the big the
big family scenes require everybody to
know their lines and luckily everybody
did because if they do then you can
really get good stuff otherwise you're
just desperately trying to catch up and
running behind on time so that was very
important and then the
you know the car chase i've shot a lot
of car chases from dukes of hazard right
so
i knew how to shoot this but i just
wanted it uh
to be
you know like we had much less time
and many fewer cars so
it was a much more of a high wire act
just to get what we got which i'm
thrilled about but
it could have gone wrong if it rained
you know completely yeah when you are
directing do you typically look for do
you expect to do like say three takes
four it takes five takes on a scene how
are you thinking about it or do you you
know what i mean like how do you like to
work on i shoot uh a
one take of the master and then maybe a
second take
because
there's only only there are only
sections of the master that ever appear
actually on screen which is the
beginning and when somebody walks across
a room
then i try to really hone in on the two
shots because the two shots are where
the actors can create their comedic
rhythm and if they keep the pace up
enough i love to use two shots because
they're they're just you know there's
some joe
uh eugene cordero two shots that i just
kept long six lines eight lines and just
let them be funny within it
but you know
i i kind of i'll shoot four or five of
those two shots and then i'll i'll make
sure that the singles are
delivered absolutely perfectly so that i
can always go to them if i have to do
you typically like to use um one camera
two cameras
are you ever shooting multiple cameras
when you're doing a comment shoot i'll
shoot two cameras um most of the time
uh if the dp is like i can't quite light
it properly if i if with the second
camera let me forget it three cameras is
hard because you have to look at three
images on the monitor and you can't do
it like two you can kind of you can kind
of see two things at once
you kind of flick back and forth i do
occasionally shoot three cameras if it's
like
you know in the church scene we you
could put another you could put a third
camera in there and it wasn't gonna get
in the way
you know in the in the picnic uh scene i
put a third camera because you're
outside and the lighting is a little
easier to manipulate that way uh you've
directed all sorts of stuff is there a
genre or type of project that you've
always been looking to do and i know
it's a little generic and you probably
could ask this before the answer but i
want to know it i want to make a um
like a modern 80s style
cop buddy movie
uh that is super funny and also violent
and the stakes are real i want to make
something in the world of 48 hours but i
want to do it transnationally between
new york and india i
like this idea a lot you've obviously
thought about this for a little bit do
you have like a script in mind or this
is just written about 35 pages of a
script i just haven't uh been able to
focus because of super troopers 3 and
some other things i understand i and i
also want as getting back to the
beginning of the interview i really do
want the super troopers 3 as a fan it's
gonna happen i i really hope it does um
on that note i'm out of time i'm just
going to say i really wish the i really
hope the film is a huge hit for you guys
thank you and uh i look forward to
helping you promote the next broken
lizard thing later this year thank you i
will also tell you i built an app called
vouchfault vouchvault right and it's
designed to be the instagram of
recommendations
and it's for movies and tv or for
everything okay okay but
the genesis of it was my uh rage against
rotten tomatoes for the 36 percent
fresh rating we got for super troopers
from 90 critics uh when in fact 250 000
civilians gave it a 90 fresh rating and
i was like
steamed and i'm like who are these
critics are just strangers and i'm like
when's the last time you walked up to a
stranger and said hey what movie should
i see now i'll say this about critics i
they have seen great movies and they
they love movies and so i want to know
what they love right so if if you go to
vouch vault and you sign up you follow
me you'll see that i love reservoir dogs
you'll see that i love this book uh
about new york city the epic of new york
city you'll see that i love this italian
place in in
hollywood you'll see that i love the
tesla car the golf clubs this podcast
it's just the stuff you love
just the stuff and if if you follow in
me and you see something you haven't
heard of it sounds intriguing you push a
button and it goes into your try vault
so on a friday when you're like what
should i watch you have a whole bunch of
things in your tri vault like the offer
or so that's that's interesting to
support if you don't mind me asking does
it correlate so it's sort of like you're
picking from
individuals and is or is there also a
way of you know bringing a lot of
recommendations together well initially
it's individuals the best way for you to
join is to join with two or three
friends and be like the sushi
restaurant's great and you know like or
you're going to paris well i put in this
paris bike trip you know like but
or if you follow celebrities or you know
influencers whatever
you like them already so you kind of
listen to their tastes you know maria
menounos recommended a bag that's on
wheels right so it's like
it's it's really that but eventually as
we get the numbers up
it'll will tell you hey you know you
pair
there's an australian
in sydney when you have 80 agreement on
these things so you might want to look
at the other 20
you might find some things you might
like uh i completely understand what
this is now and i will be happy to put
it in the
uh help you promote it i'd appreciate it
i can definitely handle this thank you
on that note uh i really do wish it i
really do hope it's a huge hit for you
guys thank you
you